وسنعيد أمريكا ، سنستعيد أمريكا
[الموسيقى]
وبعبارة أخرى ، كانت الانتخابات عملية
احتيال وإذا أردنا إنقاذ بلدنا
وجعل أمريكا عظيمة مرة أخرى ،
فلدينا خيار واحد فقط يجب أن
ننتخب أمريكا القوية التي لا تتزعزع
الجمهوريون الأوائل على كل المستويات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لذا
ما حدث هو وصمة عار
فكر في الأمر
600000 من أفضل البنادق الآلية والبنادق
المصنوعة
في أي مكان في
العالم وقرأت في اليوم الآخر أن هناك
عددًا هائلاً من معداتنا
لا يُباع الآن في السوق
السوداء بهذه الروعة
[موسيقى]
لذا
تعلمون أن
روسيا والصين لديهما بالفعل عينات من
طائرات الهليكوبتر الرائعة لدينا لدينا مروحية أباتشي ،
ونحن أفضل الأشياء في
العالم وهم  الآن يعيدون
هندسة المعدات التي يقومون
بفكها هندسيًا
ويفككونها وهم يكتشفون ذلك وقريبًا جدًا
سيبنون أفضل الأشياء مقابل
أموال أقل ، إنه وصمة عار